foreign
[Music]
California
um or the next day Friday Albia Brea
California and I got some other Brea
California dates and Charlotte
and uh Knoxville and Little Rock
Arkansas and Irvine even I'll be there
too and
um just Nashville is in September 9th
Edmonton Calgary Alberta Calgary
um Auto that's on a Montreal Hamilton
Pittsburgh Cleveland crystalia.com for
tickets
um and uh without further Ado man I
don't like what people say that but I
said it
uh the next episode of congratulations
[Music]
congratulations
I was in we also got the pockets stay
deep merch and we got the grow or die
merch which man I was in the show I did
the shows in Las Vegas this past weekend
and uh I'll tell you uh the there was a
lady there that had the grow or die
hoodie on and I was like that's a true
fan because it was
114 degrees out and you were wearing a
hoodie so thank you for supporting uh
but hopefully you didn't get heat
poisoning you know like uh Martin
Lawrence when he was doing the jogging
with the trash bags on his on his on his
upper body so
um yeah uh I I did go to Las Vegas and
it was too hot dude it was a hundred and
fifty I don't
115 degrees I I mean and you don't
here's the thing about Las Vegas is
they're like oh you don't have to ever
go outside
that's that's so it doesn't matter and
you're like you get there and you you're
like ah you gotta go outside though yeah
because
yeah I get that the places are a
One-Stop shop but also you want to go to
the other places and then they say yeah
but they're all connected and then you
go oh yeah and then the one you want to
go to is not connected right
you you're the only one that's connected
is like New York New York and you're
like yeah that's cool but I don't want I
want to go to the I want to go to Arya
and they're like where's that and
they're like it's right there they point
to it looks so close and it is 19 miles
away so that's cool
um so you gotta go outside you got to
put on sunblock and I'm not even a Mr
sunblock
I don't put on sunblock if I don't have
to but you have to there because the sun
is close the sun's like shaking hands
with you dude the sun's like uh it
sounds like your best friend and your
worst enemy just right there
and um it's just uh it was so hot and I
had to man Calvin's doing the thing
we're just like pick up pick up pick
pick up pick up so I had to walk them
everywhere I had to walk with them in on
my shoulders
and we had absolutely awesome sweat
dripping down the the armpits which is
just absolutely fabulous dude just
keeping the sides of my shirts
completely wet just absolutely damp and
absolutely fabulous just so great that
it was so damp from the sides of my
short shirt and then over into the top
of my shorts just absolutely fabulous
man just having a swamp all over my
my outfit was just absolutely great and
I had the blue palette going you know I
had the blue blue uh you know I had the
blue blue shorts and I you know I
matched the socks one day didn't mean to
but you know I guess it was subconscious
I was I was doing a blue palette in Las
Vegas whatever oh so my [__] you did it
again you know but
um
yeah he was having a palette even though
it was 114. oh so um but
um yeah uh first day went up a thousand
five hundred dollars next day went down
back to zero the next day lost three
grand the next day lost two grand yes
dude order
so he was in the whole five grand but it
was all good because he also spent some
money uh and then so if you tack it on
he had lost even more money yes dude
also went to see Devin Copperfield Yes
Man David Copperfield man Mr phoning it
in huh uh
so anyway uh I'll talk more about that
later but it's just like uh you know Las
Vegas is too hot and it's all good so
I'll talk more about that later but
right now I want to talk about I want to
talk about uh
wanna talk about uh Barbie
I'm pissed
I'm pissed they say it made 155 million
dollars just in this country I'm pissed
they say I made over 300 million dollars
worldwide I'm pissed but what I will say
is it's gonna have a sharp drop off next
week and it's gonna absolutely 100 still
bomb and everyone is like well you can't
say it bombed and I called Barbie I said
I was gonna bomb and I was right dude
and Barbie is gonna bomb and also here's
what I realized about the Barbie it
doesn't matter if it's gonna bomb do you
know why all Mattel wants to do is make
toys that's all they want to do and they
can do that they can do that with Ken
they can do that with Barbie and it's
going to make the toy sales go up I am
just so this movie I am just not into
man and I'm not seeing it and I will not
see it and I love Ryan Gosling I think
he's great I think he's a great actor
and I also think that Margot Robbie is a
great actor okay
um
and uh
I don't know man remember they're gonna
they're gonna make the movie with uh
what's her what's her name the
terrible
what's her name Amy Schumer they were
gonna make Barbie with her and then they
were just like oh wait well
what were we thinking let's get actually
the person who should be Barbie right
uh that would have been absolutely awful
I wish they made it with Amy uh Schumer
would have been the worst movie of all
time you know literally zero people
would have gone to see it would have
been an empty house
uh
uh Amy Schumer really only can do movies
where she does this on the cover of the
poster
and you can't do that on Barbie you know
just like this
oh God my life is sideways look at me I
try to fit in but I can
because of what society says
uh so
yeah dude you know yeah do I have to eat
crow on the bomb thing and the the
here's the thing dude Oppenheimer helped
it and I'm gonna I'm gonna tell you
because they branded it together it was
actually very smart of them how did it
do it how did they do it dude Barbie was
so set up for fail and it's gonna it is
gonna dude
um but it doesn't matter because they're
just trying to sell sell sell toys
Oppenheimer I'm still gonna see until I
realized dude here's the thing about
these movies man if you don't see them
opening weekend I don't [__] want to
see him
you know and I don't want to even go
opening weekend but here's the thing I
get into the hype I'm like cool I want
to see it I want to see it so bad I'm
not going to go opening weekend opening
weekend happens and then before you know
it I'm like ah wait till it comes out at
my house on on Apple TV or uh whatever
it is uh uh the rental thing and then by
the time that happens I'm like hey I'll
just watch a movie about a killer
crocodile instead you know
I don't care that much I don't care that
much I know like do I really want to sit
and watch a movie where there's you know
we're three hours long about
uh and it's only guys talking in in
buildings and [__] you know that's what
Oppenheimer is there's gonna be one one
scene where the bomb happens and beside
that it's gonna be guys talking and
[__] rooms
so you know Oppenheimer and Barbie
they're doing great I think Oppenheimer
is going to do very very well I think
Barbie's gonna have a sharp drop off
Mission Impossible had a sharp drop off
dude because it was because of the you
know Mission Impossible was that was
gonna be the [__] and then had a sharp
drop off and that's too bad because I
love Jeremy Renner but who knows man a
lot of people watching Mission
Impossible that's that's a good
franchise but Tom Cruise man this is the
thing man you got to be
I don't like these celebrities that are
just like everything's great
everything's hunky dory I'm gonna do
everything you know they interviewed Tom
Cruise did it I I I I talked about it
last uh podcast
you know I took some clips with out
there went stupid viral me just making
fun of this [__] you know and um
yeah dude
I just
Ryan Ryan uh gossing and and Margot
Robbie can't do no wrong though they
could they could make a movie called
like the [__] Chronicles and uh Ryan
Gosling could play literally a [__]
piece of [__] coming out of an [__]
and they'll be like and the academy
would be like dude we got to consider it
we got to consider it right
is acting Stillness dude
Stillness
um
but yeah I don't know
I was I want to see you know what I want
to see sound of Freedom dude can't wait
to see this movie
with Jim Caviezel I already talked about
this last time but I can't wait to see
uh sound of freedom because
um I gotta see Jim I didn't know Jim
Caviezel actually believes that people
drink adrenochrome or is that what it is
called
adrenochrome the blood of children
to uh become younger all right crazy
it's all good all right crazy which is
all code
it's all good man hey man
hey man you're in frequency so it's all
good man you know hey dude oh [__] man
yeah you're in frequency dude I can't
wait to see sound of Freedom though
because it's awesome I think it's so
[__] that uh the media is trying to
[__] bury it because they think it it
it pushes q and on theories I don't care
anymore push Q Anon theories
I am killing on
but yeah I do it but Jim Caviezel did
the second start talking about how you
know what I mean
Hollywood stars are drinking
adrenochrome from children's blood hey
man just remember you're in frequency
okay so it's all good man uh hey dude
real quick you're gonna move with Dennis
Quaid call frequency this is all good
man dude don't even worry about it man
so don't even worry about that man
uh
uh I was in uh Vegas and it was 115
degrees and wait before I even want to
talk about that there is a festival in
uh Detroit that happens every year Ella
this is great dude oh I can't wait to
post this as a clip oh it just got me oh
it just got me it just got me oh Dale
dude there's a festival in
Detroit and I'm going to tell you right
now I have no idea what it's about no
idea I have zero clue what it is I still
don't know I think it's like a bizarre
thing and and I don't mean like whoa
what the hell is that you know bizarre
like that's a weird thing it's like in
the in the traditional sense it's like a
bizarre where people are they don't put
in bazaars you know they don't put masks
on they just like hold the mask on with
their [__] thing with their little
you know uh stick whatever it is but
there's a festival in Detroit apparently
they have it every year I have no idea
um
about it up until three two days ago
I am going to be in Detroit October 21st
get your tickets at the Jack White
theater chrisley.com
I guess
that week or something is usually
reserved for some thing
some Festival okay
so I booked this show in Detroit
Michigan
I don't know three months ago
two days ago I get an onslaught of
messages [__] you dude you're destroying
jobs in Detroit
your hundreds of people are are are
begging on this you're ruining hundreds
of thousands of dollars
in in our Detroit economy because of
[__] you
and I see all these comments and I go
huh
the lovely comedian goes huh hey you're
taking our date that we have every year
our economy thrives
and I go huh they say you're ruining it
and I go huh I do a little bit of
research still can't figure out what's
going on people are just slaughtering me
in my comments you piece of [__] cancel
the date now they're saying
I got comments DMs
crystallia cancel the date now and I now
you know what it is now you oh you know
what it is you know what it is when
people come at me like that I go like
this no
I don't even know what's going on by the
way see here's the here's the toxicity
of our city of our city dude you gotta
have a dialogue come at me regular hey
did you know that there is a festival
that's now not gonna happen because and
by the way dude it's not gonna happen
because of me
if it's sold well and if it was the [__]
like you say it is it would still be
there you know why you know why I do it
capitalism that's why
I'ma sell this [__] out I don't know
what I don't even know what the [__]
thing is every year I don't know what it
is the theater goes like this yeah
crystalia come perform
I say okay
and now three months later oh they're
not having the I can't hold my mask up
like this
and throw a [__] bean bag out at a
Target and make a guy with you know
puffy pants fall in a in a [__] dunk
tank all right dude don't come at me
like that
don't come at me like that I don't give
a [__] now whoops
I done now don't give a [__]
how do you sit I want you to understand
something if these people sincerely
asked me and said man I'm really
heartbroken this sucks like you know
usually we do this and that I would have
actually investigated it I would have
actually asked my people about hey what
is this I don't want to ruin this [__]
but now
oh good
I'll be there
it's not how it works dude don't push me
that's what I say so now can't wait to
perform in Detroit can't wait to roast
you [__] [__] when I'm there
I'm coming out like this with one of
these
and big pants with the [__] shitty
argyle socks
hello welcome to the Chrisley show
grab your seats settle in for a dark
tale and I'm just gonna [__] talk
about like [__] myself in cell
phones like my whatever my ACT is you
know
that's disrespect dude
that's kind of [__] cancel your show now
by the way everyone who wrote me it was
like a cartoon Avatar
it's just so [__] like go [__]
yourself dude I don't know about this I
don't know about this it's not my fault
and me and another comedian was another
night I don't even know the guy but it
was like it was like you and you cancel
the show and I go like this [__] hell
no dude I'm gonna start a tour with that
other comedian and I'm just gonna run
every every year same year it's going to
be the crystalia festival now in Detroit
so thank you very much nice to meet you
all good thank you very much nice to
meet you anyway buy tickets for the
Detroit show October 21st it's almost
sold out
and I guess your [__] wasn't going to be
I don't know otherwise it would be there
every year so that's all good great now
more reason more reason for people to
hate me all good morning for people to
hate me all good you can't win anyway so
it doesn't matter so I'm just like toss
a coin dude you're with your Valley of
plenty oh Valley of Plenty
toss a coin to your Witcher dude you
watch The Witcher Ah that's your [__]
sucks doesn't it man you know what I'm
not even hating man what's going on I
watched five episodes of that what's
going on huh hey show what's going on
hey show have a color in it huh
everything's [__] a version of gray
what's going on man hey dude I want this
Henry Cavill no dude with the long gray
hair hey scone on dude I can't even
believe that show dude that show makes
no sense what's going on dude The
Witcher is first of all dude what is a a
Witcher is a guy who apparently goes
fights Beasts for money which they call
a coin okay all right all good but also
hey uh
pick a different name because a witch is
a chick and now he's just a Witcher
that's like calling a guy Barbie man or
something that's so [__] okay it's so
[__]
as as I call the guy Mr Betty Boop hey
leave it for the chicks you're not a
witch have a different name all right
like you know Voldemort is cool but
that's taken so which ER [__] and then
also dude Henry Cavill he's an okay
actor and I stand by that dude the only
time he was ever oscar-worthy is when he
cocked his biceps and last mission
impossible [__] okay and when the cgied
his mustache on the when they cgied over
his mustache for the reshoots and the
Superman movie because he was shooting
Mission Impossible already and they
wanted to reshoot the movie for DC and
they had a scene and Mission Impossible
was like no he can't shave he needs to
be having this mustache for the actual
rest of the film filming of the movie uh
uh Mission Impossible and so DC was like
well we'll just uh uh CGI it out was
that Zack Snyder who did that [__] and
it looked like [__] utter trash dude
and I loved it Oscar and the Oscar for
worst CGI I goes to
Superman and Batman or whatever the [__]
that movie was Superman vs Batman I
don't know what it was but dude The
Witcher episode 4 at the end I'm like I
think maybe I understand what's going on
or I'm not sure and then all of a sudden
somebody starts floating for no reason
and becomes someone else and I go like
this
can't
I just these [__] and it's a video
game dude video game it's I get the IP
the intellectual property is you know
it's so successful people are going to
watch it anyway but God damn dude that
show sucks donkey balls and it's all
good
but I'll tell you what is absolutely the
[__] the song and I'm not bullshitting
but the guy I never thought of like a
song with the mandolin ever in my life
I never thought I'd like a song with
Amanda Lynn
and this [__] bangs he goes
or Valley of plenty oh toss a coin to
your Witcher dude your Witcher
like we each have one
um I don't know man
what shows are good I have no idea I
haven't really seen a [__] good show
tomorrow
I saw David Copper oh this is the Hayden
episode man
I guess what do I love I gotta start
talking about things I love
I don't know man I woke up one day in
Vegas
and my wife is like guess what I said
huh and she said
Kona David go to David Copperfield
tonight
I go like this
oh for [__] sake
inside I'm in my brain that's what I do
and I say oh cool
she said yeah got eight tickets
and I go oh for [__] sake everybody's
coming yeah
oh
so I'm like great
down another G
so I'm like also David Copperfield
though kind of synonymous with magic so
I'm like okay cool I'll watch kind of
was excited about it to be honest also
didn't have to be in a 115 degree Heat
then I Googled David Copperfield dude
he's worth a billion dollars
hey
he's worth he's a billionaire
it's hey
how it's not real it's not actually
happening okay
but you know what I mean like he's a
magician it's all fake we all know it
hey he's a billionaire that's insane to
me
what he is doing is bullshitting and
he's a billionaire for that
that's crazy
I don't I think magicians are
like I like Justin Willman is that his
name he's good because he's like doing
the [__] and it's like kind of funny and
cute and [__] like there are cool but
the second it's like they're like
like all right buddy we know it's not
happening stop with the eyebrow [__]
there's one part where David Garfield
goes like this at the end he just at the
end of a trick he literally goes like
this
and I was like dude
cool it
he goes one time he went like this
and then went like this
twice dude like he was so mighty Duty 66
and it is
eh so phoning it in dude it was
unbelievable
dude he comes out like hey I'm Deborah
Caulfield so I was born at the time when
I was born I had a dinosaur little toy
dinosaur and you know and rolled around
with the dinosaur I was in every picture
he shows pictures of him holding the
dinosaur when he's a little kid and
they're all photoshopped and in the me
and immediately you're like oh these
pictures are real dude and I had one
gold tooth and I thought and I always
wanted to happen and you're just like
what's going on dude and then he does
some tricks where you're like okay I
maybe see how he does it but I don't
know how he did it really and then he
pops a balloon in another balloon and
that is amazing to pop a balloon in
another balloon is [__] amazing all
right he just has a balloon and another
balloon stares at it the balloon in the
inside pops the blue one on the outside
does not pop now
that was my favorite trick did he make a
UFO appear out of nowhere yes did he
make a tyrannus Rex Tyrannosaurus Rex
appear out of nowhere yes okay did he
make a guy disappear in the crowd yes
everyone thought that those were the
best tricks dude no I only want the
subtle [__] because that's the [__] I
can't explain somehow dude he made a
whole [__] alien ship
appear man
he made a whole [__] alien ship
appear above us and everyone goes whoa
and I'm like yeah but they probably have
a propeller or drones and obviously came
from the stage but dude popping a
balloon inside another balloon do all
that sort of [__] all the time
but yeah but this [__] though where
you're just like
I'll never tell and it's like okay okay
then you know then just do it you know
then just don't tell us and just it's
like but a billionaire
all magicians should make ninety
thousand dollars a year
period there that should be it should be
like that's the cap
for The Magician's League
you cannot make more than 90
000.
how many of them would still do it for
the love then huh
I admire David Copperfield though I
really do because man
he's 66. he married Claudia Schiffer
first of all who is like one of the
hottest babes of all time
and then uh you know I get divorced
obviously so is she like a 500
millionaire
what dude I don't know but this guy does
he's 66 he did three shows on a Saturday
so I was like well he must be loving it
and then I watched and uh phone it in so
I'm like why is he doing it
anyway
um
God bless dude I love it
David conference go I want to meet him
magicians are [__] weird huh Vegas is
weird right
Vegas is so weird I was in Vegas right
obviously you know this past weekend
I'm chilling and so many people come up
to me in Vegas you know because they're
drunk and they're just like whoa dude
what's up man hey I watch your podcast
or whatever and uh
this one dude
comes up to me I'm sitting because David
Sullivan was there and of course he like
put a hundred a hundred dollar bill in
like a slot machine to have credits and
then it broke and then he had to call
somebody and they came and like opened
up the whole thing and he was like man
my Dollar's all my hundred dollars bills
all caught in there we gotta wait for
them to open it up they opened it up and
[__] and so I'm sitting there with them
and some dude I see as I'm walking over
I see some dude walk by me and let me
just say something you're not slick okay
I know when you know it notice me all
right it's like a hot chick
right they just walk into the Starbucks
and [__] up the room and everybody's
like oh let's not look at her she knows
what's going on all right now I'm not
saying everybody knows who I am they
don't but when somebody does I I can
usually tell right this guy is dressed
in all white which all right it's fine
because of how you're in Vegas but you
could tell this guy dresses in all white
period just outside of Vegas which is
crazy all right super tall lanky dude I
see him walk by I see him clock me I
walk over to David sit down and tell me
about this whole hundred dollar deal
ordeal and the guy walks up to me again
and I see him because he's wearing all
white right at the corner of my eye okay
I'm not a hippo but I see him
and he comes up to me and he stares at
me and he stares at me for a few beats
with his hands in his pockets and he's
like this
and I stare back
and I don't play that [__] okay I don't
play that [__]
I stare back
until you speak I don't break gays it's
gonna be weird but it's gonna be more
weird for you all right
[Music]
the only way you can beat me with that
is if you're on drugs
and this guy was on some kind of drug
apparently because I stayed staring at
him while he was going like this
for
God it was nine seconds
it was so uncomfortable and then I
finally go like this
hey what's up and he says so awesome
dude
and I said oh yeah he said so awesome
so cool man so cool that you're here I
mean just experiencing this is amazing
and I'm like oh [__]
and he says just absolutely I mean so
talented
and I'm like oh well thank you man thank
you and then he says such Grace
and I say oh yeah and he says yeah man
seriously
and then I say well I appreciate you man
and then he just goes like this
and I'm like
another guy walks up to me and says
are you I think you are and I'm like
guys you know I don't I don't know who
you think I am you know he's like
because I thought I recognized you is
this guy the comedian and the other
guy's like yeah man it's him
and I'm like guys I'm here you know and
then the the guy who walked up second
says
oh man it's cool to see you had a uh
like a cigar that was it was like hey
bro that's done it was so tiny and just
like
he was like what's up dude and I was
like hey man like these guys were acting
like I wanted to be in this conversation
it was unbelievable one guy was on like
Molly or whatever and the other guy was
just a [__] okay and he was just like
what's up dude and he was wearing a polo
shirt and shorts dude it was 1am and he
says and he's smoking a cigar and he
says what's up dude and I was like hey
man and he says man yeah you're really
funny I said oh cool and he says yeah
I'm an actor but I'm mostly model
mm-hmm
and I said oh well of course
like he's handsome right
I don't know if you heard me or not and
then he says yup I said oh that's cool
he says
it's a [__] grind man
I said oh yeah what is
and he says acting man I work my ass off
dude all I've said so far in this
conversation to either of these guys is
uh yeah
oh oh yeah and these guys are having a
full-on conversation like we're the
second hour in a Joe Rogan podcast okay
he says yeah I work my [__] ass off I
said oh well that's good and he said
yeah uh-huh I work hard
and then a beat goes by I look at the
man in white he's still just looking at
me like this
and then the actor Model guy says
only 25 people have gotten to my level
and I go
well now I'm in
and I said oh [__] he said Yup I said
well what level is that and he explains
to me that he got into a
School of acting that only 25 people got
in and he was one of them and I said oh
well that's really cool and he said Yup
and next month
I'm going to an expo in Dallas
you know
but I just said oh that's cool an expo
in Dallas huh that's it sveg first of
all an expo in Dallas I mean I don't
know what the [__] it's an acting thing
also Dallas isn't the hotbed for like
young new actor I don't know
then my buddy Sam was like buddy this
guy over here wants a picture and I was
like oh yeah come over and the guy
wanted the picture was like oh dude I
don't want to interrupt you I said
interrupt me you're [__] saving me so
I took a picture of a bro holy [__] man
Vegas is so we're the only place the
only places where those types of things
happen are either Vegas or New York in
like the middle of the day or if you're
at a nightclub in LA that's it it
doesn't happen anywhere else period
um and then we started gambling I
started going on craps or not crap sorry
I played roulette a little bit first
and this dude was
this handsome dude who was like 54.
just betting
thousands of dollars each roulette like
I'm talking about
there was like
there were like spins that had 10 000 of
his dollars on the board
and he was just like what does it matter
what does it matter you know what does
it matter eh what does it matter he kept
saying and I was like well yeah he's
like it doesn't matter you put this here
you put this there it doesn't matter
he's telling me and he starts telling me
jokes like jokes you'd read from a book
but here's what happened he goes like
this
he puts a five thousand dollar chip on
three
okay
he's got a one in 37 chance of turning
this into 180
okay or whatever it is
so he puts it on three the things
spinning right before the dealer says no
more bets the dealer or whatever you
call him because he's not dealing
anything really takes the Chip And he
says I don't think you really want to
make that bet do you tosses it off back
to the guy and then the [__] ball
lands on free
okay
so the guy says what the hell did you
take that off for
and the guy says well I didn't think you
really wanted to bet on it and he says
but that's why I'll put it there and he
says Nah well it doesn't you know it
wasn't there so we can't pay you and the
guy's like I put it on there
and then he says get the Pit Boss
because this guy's owed a hundred and
eighty thousand dollars
The Pit Boss comes by and is like what
happened here we explain and the Pit
Boss says no the maximum bet here is 500
so that bet is void anyway you're
getting nothing and then David Sullivan
was there and he says nah man I saw it
that's not fair he put that chip there
he should get that money you should at
least give him the 500 bet which is 18
Grand okay and the Pit Boss says this
has got nothing to do with you to David
Sullivan and David Sullivan says yes it
does I was a witness and I was like
that's actually pretty dope he was
witnessing it doesn't have something to
do
so the Pit Boss leaves to make a call I
don't know what we call like Jesus
Christ or something I don't know who
above is above in The Pit Boss but he's
on the phone for [__] 15 minutes and
I'm chilling we can't do anything else
so we're just the Spanish Guy starts
saying like
like just he was so from a goddamn movie
it was unbelievable first of all waiting
to see if he's going to get 18 000 cool
as a cucumber betting thousands and
thousands of dollars
and says a guy walks into a bar and I
was like dude are you are you kidding me
like are you kidding me right now a guy
walks into a bar he opens up the box
says to the bartender what do you
think's in this little box tells me some
sort of and I'm like oh yo dude we're
not doing this
I gotta now I gotta pretend to laugh at
your jokes tells me a joke it's fine you
know it's a written joke he obviously
read it somewhere and then we were like
oh yeah that's funny yeah and David
Sullivan under breath says I heard that
one man so it's like oh yeah
next one
it was a sunny there's another joke
second joke and he says I'm sorry man
but I'm just waiting biting time I'm
really sorry that all this is happening
and I said it's okay man he says what do
you guys do I said well we're all
Comedians and he says oh no he gets
embarrassed because you're ton of
[__] jokes there's hilarious
The Pit Boss comes back
and says okay we'll give you the
eighteen thousand dollars so this dude
just makes eighteen thousand dollars off
of the one hand right and then says
thank you for guys for being with me and
actually like having my back and [__] I
want to come to your show tomorrow and I
want to take you all to dinner
so we did we went to dinner with a guy
named Emmanuel who is Spanish
and it was [__] so good dude and that
[__] is Vegas
it was so gangster
I loved it
at least there's the two types of people
in Vegas you know there's the fun Vegas
is knots dude
look at this Tom Cruise
hold up
there we go here's Tom Cruise
movies popcorn
staged
[Music]
movies popcorn dude
I love my popcorn
movies popcorn hey guy
you're fabricated
dude
I don't dislike Tom Cruise I love Tom
Cruise all the Scientology [__] is very
[__] weird though why
does like why is that okay you know it's
so [__] weird that he's such a big
star and a Scientologist and like
Scientology is so [__] up
and the media is just like so what do
you feel about it Barbie
like
ask him where Shelley miskovich is or
whatever the [__] that lady's name is
so Tom do you do your own stunts hey
he's a Scientologist
all questions should be in that Realm
so what's the weird thing about [__]
not being able to leave or you guys got
your own underwear or what's the deal
they got blackmail on you
the guy can't say [__] dude now he can't
be him this is my nightmare
movies
dude
I love my popcorn also if you're gonna
fabricate this [__] at least take half
the popcorn out and make it look like
he's actually eating he he has eaten
some it's so mounded up dude
you know you know after that he got up
and he was like all right so what's your
next interview
god dude
it's creepy it's downright creepy
actually
and I love Tom Cruise but like it's just
so [__] weird
Scientology is just what the [__] dude
any religion that's like really really
really hardcore what the [__]
but I don't know anything about it to be
really honest with you
so and also I guess Jamie Foxx is okay
but he was fighting for his life a
little bit I think
everybody is prayed man and sent me
messages
I cannot even begin to tell you
um
how far it took me and how how it
brought me back
um
uh I went through something that I
thought I would never ever go through
uh and I know a lot of people were
waiting you know or wanting to hear
updates but to be honest with you
I just didn't want you to see me like
that man you know I want you to see me
laughing and having a good time partying
cracking a joke doing a movie television
show I didn't want you to see me with a
with tubes
um
running out of me and
and trying to figure out you know
if
if I was gonna
make it through and to be honest with
you my uh my sister deidrediction my
daughter Corinne Marie saved my life so
oh yeah to them to God
to a lot of great medical people uh I'm
able to leave you this
uh video
I cannot tell you how great it feels to
have
your family kick in in such a way and
y'all know they kept it airtight they
didn't let nothing out they protected
that was crazy actually what I hope that
everyone could have in the moments I
can't believe they kept it under wraps
now you know by being quiet
sometimes things you know get out of
hand people saying what I got some
people said I was I was blind but as you
can see uh
as you can see the eyes are working the
eyes are working just fine uh I said I
was paralyzed I'm not paralyzed
um but I did go through I went to hell
and back and my road to recovery had
some potholes as well but uh damn dude
people are like I love how people are
just so disrespectful and like yo they
cloned that they clone that full
like this guy almost died and like
there's literally people out there like
yo that's a clone man look his eyes are
further apart
they [__] it up that's a clone man
they [__] up the first two versions
that's why it took so long and then this
is the third this is Jamie Foxx three
um it would be great if he was like man
I went to hell I'm back
and just a beam of light came out of his
[__] mouth and you were and that's
how we realized that we were under
attack oh hell yeah that would be
amazing
yeah
um I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm coming back
and uh I'm able to work and then also
some people are like oh this is PR for
his new movie which is just like just so
disrespectful the guy almost died you
know
uh people that let me work
um and I just want to like say that I
that I I love everybody and I love
all the love that I got
yeah that's cool man you know I know
they talk about people crying on videos
you know you could do take two but
yeah it's true
that's crazy here here's here's here's
honestly for real
I'm being honest
this is how this is Tom Cruise watching
that video
movies popcorn
[Music]
look at this comment not into
Scientologist TBH I have avoided his
movies for over a decade cool man you're
really sticking it to him
guys are [__] trillionaire
wow
God Scientology is so [__] weird man
what's this here
well this is my favorite when people
alienate fans
uh Doja cat shits on fans slams kittens
nickname grow up get a job I guess
that's what her fans are called kittens
is that right
Doja cat appears to be opening up a can
of tough love on her staunchest fans
rebuking a pet name they've given
themselves and I mean that is so [__]
dorky to be calling yourself kittens
dude like for real
I mean we call ourselves babies but
that's [__] badass
the rapper singer has been getting some
side eye from Aloha supporters over
there my fans don't name themselves [__]
if you call yourself a kitten or [__]
kittens that means you need to get off
your phone and get a job and help your
parents with the house
I mean dude biting them mouth that
friggin feeds you
um
what is this [__]
the rapper series uh it all appears to
have come to a head this weekend when
she shot down a term a lot of them used
which is kind of in the vein of Nicki
Minaj stands dude women
the only person that doesn't the the
women [__]
hate women you know what I mean like
even if they don't know they see a woman
doing better than them or coming up and
they go [__] that [__] in their head
and then they say hi
this is the worst part about women is
that they [__] hate women dude I'm
I'm generally generally speaking
um
but also Dodge cars obviously crazy so
I just it's so crazy how women do that
[__]
they'll tear you the [__] down
's cool though man
um
she's a [__] huge singer huh
bro
this [__]
I can't believe this happened the other
day dude David Sullivan doesn't eat
cheese okay
he doesn't eat dairy
because he says I'll [__] my pants man
I don't do it to you
they're solving my friend if you're new
to this podcast
and he says so he's over one one night
and we're eating we're gonna I say let's
order burgers
and and so I Postmates a burger place
that I want
it's me one of our friends and David
okay
and Dave is the kind of guy who anybody
who makes any sort of amendments on food
I'm like all right dude you know just
get it the way they want you to get it
they figured it out stop it with the
[__] the the Postmates with the oh
but no onions but substitute [__]
pickled onions and you're just like oh
[__] no what do you want what do you got
here
if I want to make some I'll make it at
home
you know
so I I look I picked the burger and I
say what do you want he says oh you just
give me what you get but actually let me
just actually change it because I want
to get no cheese and no mayo because I
don't get
I don't get I don't eat dairy we've been
watching a movie and I don't want to be
[__] blasting you to Mars and I'm
like
then get something completely different
because you know why because they're
gonna [__] it up for me you know what
I'm saying right you know what I'm
saying if you ordered one thing and then
you order the other same thing but it's
a little bit amended they're gonna make
them both that way and I'm not gonna get
my party going
for me my shit's gonna come Mayo listen
Jesus
and he was like man come on man I want
to get the burger so I was like dude
okay okay
fine but if it comes [__] up and if my
shit's [__] up dude look at me and I
made him look at me I said you better
not fart
right you better not [__] fart
because
it'll be worth it if you don't fart if
my [__] comes like how about communist
gets it I don't even know do hamburgers
exist or do you just get a cheeseburger
without cheese who the [__] eats a
hamburger That's crazy dude
to be like like have you even seen
hamburger on a menu since 1981
that's like Russian or something
so I ordered the thing and our friend
Jerica is like oh uh uh I'm gonna get
one a a different Burger
hers is regular with cheese and [__] but
not the one I got but David got the one
I got without the cheesing out the mail
Mayo's cool because I got Mayo if that
doesn't come okay if the cheese doesn't
come I'm [__] right
so the burgers come Jericho gets the
food brings it up checks the burgers
ladies and gentlemen we have two burgers
that David Sullivan would like
we have no Burgers crystally I would
like ladies and gentlemen we have two
mayolus and cheeseless burgers and
Jerrica got hers the way she wanted
ladies and gentlemen David Sullivan
better not [__] fart ladies and
gentlemen
here lies two [__] up hamburgers
before you and thank God they're from a
really great high-end burger place
otherwise Chris DeLeo would be so
[__] goddamn mad that he would get an
ulcer because at least it'll be good
without the cheese because it's a
high-end place so I'm like you know what
dude God damn it [__] I told you
dude and then Jericho's like dude you
got white American cheese you could just
heat it up but I'm like
everything's got to be the same temp if
it's different temps in the [__]
layers what am I doing it's not dessert
you can't get a brownie heated up with
also ice cream on it you can do it for
dessert but this is a burger
so I go give me the [__] thing start
the goddamn movie I'm I'm just I'm gonna
eat it I guess I'm gonna pretend it has
cheese on it
I'm eating the [__] Burger it's still
kind of good but I'm so pissed off I
[__] you not dude
we're halfway into act one
bro
David Sullivan farted so loud I thought
a boat was docking it was so it was so
dude it was one of those
like and I and I go oh come on and I
didn't get the cheeseburger that's what
I say and bro it was so maddening I said
well then what the [__] you said it was
Dairy is it dude he said oh no man it
must have been a little mail on that or
something bro
power to the Moon
now I gotta watch the [__] movie all
the way over on the other side of the
couch and he's lighting them up he just
light him up and I said dude keep him
inside and he says nah man that's bad
for you dude and then I say no it's not
it's fine and then Jericho says actually
is bad for you and I go oh all right you
know what you had your cheeseburger
you're happy why don't you pipe down
it's not bad for you to keep your farts
in man and I read an article where it's
like it is kind of bad for you but it's
not though man what does it take your
life expectancy down no what do you get
his tummy ache let's go back up in you
and you [__] burp
you burp later that's what happens
I cannot believe that that happened and
that's the kind of [__] that's the worst
kind of [__]
oh no this guy this is what made me
think of it this guy farted
this guy farted while I Swang the golf
club I'm pleased to announce that
Francesco Molinari just farted when
hitting his first tee shot
come on
be real
it's real
oh dude that's cheating
he got propelled
no they're clapping they don't know
the quietness of it
oh dude
Here Comes Francesco Molinari
needs Park oh boy okay well that was
I might have shot a little bit
the best part was it wasn't a good shot
it went into the [__] roughage
holy crap
roughage what'd I say
yeah yeah what's it called
the rough it roughage
um
that is crazy went into the cabbage
yeah the I guess [__] man it's gonna
be I can't believe it's so you know
what's crazy is how quickly the world's
changing like Twitter changed to X I
guess or they're going to or something
um Elon Musk and that's so weird that it
happened after like right after the
threads thing it must be in some sort of
trouble I mean it has to be if it's
rebranding
and [__] and Twitter's just been getting
more and more awful I actually don't
[__] know I don't use Twitter I just
know it's awful
um it's always been awful I know it
hasn't always been awful in the
beginning was awesome you know it was
like oh we were figuring uh who knew
that it was going to become this huge
[__] thing
um but Twitter is now X I guess did he
make any sort of statement about it or
or he did
um
so I guess they're rebranding it and
people will find a problem with that but
I guess this is I don't know if
Twitter's days are limited or what or or
numbered I should say
um I don't feel like that [__] uh
what is it uh threads is really picking
up any steam uh I although I don't know
I I just I just kind of like look at it
every now and then just because it's a
part of Instagram which was cool that he
did that but I don't know isn't isn't it
all
it's all [__] garbage it's all
garbage
okay well that's good that's it thank
you very much I appreciate you oh leave
a message uh under here uh like And
subscribe we'd appreciate it and uh also
it would be really cool if you left a
comment thanks a lot
um and share it with your friends this
podcast is uh is really great and it's
really great because of you guys because
you you it's not really great without
you guys so thanks and uh if you want to
sign up for the patreon and get the
extended version of congratulations
the uncut unedited version of
congratulations each episode go to
patreon.com crystalia and also there's
an extra episode a month there's like 30
something episodes now that you can go
look at if you just
go and uh go to patreon.com and it's
like six bucks so thank you very much
appreciate you uh and don't forget to
pick up with that merch okay see you
guys
[Music]